>> Mark Walker AKA Professor
Horn: Thank you so much.
Can you hear me OK on this?
OK, good. It's a real
pleasure to be here today.
It's-- I've been here
doing research at times
at the Houdini Library and
I-- it's nothing like it.
So, it's wonderful to be here.
Punch and Judy is somewhat of
an esoteric subject matter here
in America and I could
talk about it for hours.
And if anybody has their
doubts, just ask my poor wife.
OK? Now, a few important things.
Some homework first.
We have a tremendous amount
of information to cover
and in order to keep things
interesting and moving along,
I need to compress
tons of information
into an allotted time slot.
So, if there are any questions,
I would just say speak to me
at the very end of the
program and I'll be happy
to talk to you about that.
So, exactly what
is Punch and Judy?
In its simplest form, Punch is
a nonsensical slapstick comedy
puppet show about
a misfit family.
Think in terms of the
cartoon show the Simpsons,
but in our case, however,
it's Marge, Homer, Bart,
and Lisa Simpson meet Tom and
Jerry and The Three Stooges.
Much like the move Napoleon
Dynamite, the show has no plot,
but somehow it still works.
While the show itself has a very
loose structure, no two Punch
and Judy shows are the same.
And much like-- much of the
play is left to the imagination
of the showman and that's
what makes it both interesting
and fun.
You can still see versions
of the puppet show performed
in countries around the world.
I'm kind of new at this-- let's
see here-- let me just try this.
There we go.
OK. And here it is, some
great examples of that.
What is not shown
here is, in Russia,
Punch is known as Petrushka.
In Germany, it's Kasperle.
France, it's Polichinelle.
Italy, it's Pulcinella.
And of course here in the U.S.
and England it's known as Punch.
So the $64,000 question
is how did one
of the oldest folk dramas begin.
It took several hundred years
for the dramatis persona
to emerge and evolve into
the puppet show it is today.
There we go.
For this lecture, though,
we're going to begin
at about the middle
of the 16th century
with a character
known as Pulcinella.
He was just one of many comical
stock characters appearing
in a repertoire of plays put
on by a group of actors known
as the commedia dell'arte.
The theater of skills.
Pulcinella had a large nose,
he wore a floppy white costume
with a pointed hat, and
although he was witty back then,
he was somewhat of an
idiot and a coward.
Over the years, this
traveling group
of minstrels toured the
surrounding areas presenting
their plays and so
popular was the character
that the puppeteers of the day
added him to their puppet shows.
And so it was just a matter
of time before they
traveled throughout Europe.
And we know that one
of these shows was seen
in England on May ninth of 1662.
Was anybody there to see that?
I was just checking.
OK. OK. And the reason we know
that is there was a man named--
that's right-- Samuel Pepys.
He was a government minister.
He kept a diary and in
his journal he noted
that he had been at an
alehouse in Covent Garden
and he was there looking at
a painting and as he came
out he noticed this pretty
Italian puppet play, Pulcinella.
Now, it wasn't a puppet show per
se, but it was a puppet play.
And he was so taken
by the performance
that he told his wife and
his servants to go see it.
The name of the performer
was Pietro Gimonde
and because he was from Bologna,
which is in northern Italy,
he was called Signor Bologna.
Makes sense to me.
OK. He was travelling throughout
Europe and he happened
to make a stop in England where
he stayed for many months.
And everywhere he went,
the show was noted
for its chief character,
a hooknose clown
with a black half mask
and a squeaky voice.
In October of that year,
Signor Bologna gave
a royal performance--
command performance-- for King
Charles II and the monarch was
so impressed with him that
he gave him a gold chain
and a medal as a way of
showing his appreciation.
Let me try to get this here.
Boo. There we go.
OK. This is Martin Powell.
This is about 1709 and
that's Punch and Mrs. Punch.
Now, I should point out
that the puppet shows
at that particular time,
they were marionettes.
That's puppets with strings.
Several puppeteers were needed
in order to present these shows
on these large makeshift stages.
Each puppet was probably
about three feet high.
Other Italian performers
heard of Bologna's success
and before long they headed to
England where the popularity
of the marionette was
rapidly being established.
Now, many of the shows
started working large fairs,
such as Bartholomew Fair,
Norridge, and all over England.
The shows, however,
were a bit tacky.
You had to go into a marquee
and stand in the dark.
And there were prostitutes,
pickpockets, and all sort
of things going on
in the darkness.
During the next 100 years,
the people of England grabbled
with the name of this character
and eventually his name was
shortened from Pulcinella
to Punchinello and
eventually Punch.
Other characters
began to emerge.
One of the earliest
characters was the devil,
who fought Mr. Punch at
the very end of the story.
By the 1700's, Mr. Punch's wife
was introduced to the show.
And at that time
her name was Joan.
And because it was
pronounced through a swazzle--
that's a little device that
the performer puts in his mouth
that gives Punch
the squeaky voice.
But when he would call her
name, he would call Joan,
but he would call her
Joanie and people heard that
and thought he was saying Judy,
so eventually that's how it
became known as Punch and Judy.
Now, as time passed by, these
marionette shows started
to play themselves out.
One of the main reasons was
that the overhead costs.
Some of the marionette
shows required four
or more entertainers to
erect a large puppet theater
and perform the show.
That's a lot of people to feed,
especially when you're busking,
which means you're
working for tips.
Here we go.
All right.
Yeah. About 1779, Punch
evolved into a hand puppet,
which was much more viable
than the old marionette shows.
One man could now operate the
puppets behind this portable
stage and it's-- although
it's not shown here,
but in many instances his
partner would stand in front
of the puppet theater, he'd
bang a drum and play panpipes
in order to attract a crowd
so they could collect money.
It was a very short show.
If you look at this
copper engraving,
you'll notice how tall the
puppet stage is compared to some
of the other people
standing near it.
What you don't see is behind the
curtain a performer is holding
the puppets above his
head, and that was
so that people could see
it from a greater distance.
Now, all the action took
place on a small puppet stage
and often times the
puppets collided
when they came together.
Since Punch was a hand puppet,
he could now pick up a stick
and belabor anyone who stopped
him from having his own way.
That meant the law,
his wife, the devil.
No doubt one day the wooden
baby puppet fell off the stage,
it got a laugh, and
other performers
of the day added
it to their show.
Punch's costume was
originally all white,
but through the years he
acquired the red, yellow,
and green motley colors
of the Elizabethan jester.
Lots of English puns and sense
of humor began creeping
into the show.
Soon it became a very
funny puppet play.
Punch would ridicule
people in high places,
deflate the pompous,
and to some people
of the time, he was
on their side.
And in a day when they would
hang you for stealing a loaf
of bread, when Mr. Punch was
confronted by the hangman,
Jack Ketch, and Punch
tricked the hangman
into putting his own noose--
I mean his own head into
the noose, audiences thought
that was a wonderful achievement
and Punch became a folk hero.
Now, an important point
to remember is that up
until this time the shows
were never written down.
Once an entertainer learned
a show, he learned how
to present it, he
passed that knowledge
on to either his son
or an apprentice.
And in many respects, that's how
that tradition continues
to this day.
Matter of fact, that's
exactly how I learned the show,
which you'll hear about
a little bit later.
The structure of
the play, however,
became formally established
in 1828
when the first recorded
script was captured
in a book called the
tragical comedy or comic--
comical tragedy of
Punch and Judy.
It was written by a
journalist, John Payne Collier,
and the book had
wonderful illustrations
by George Cruikshank.
And I actually have some of
those that are on display here.
Through text and drawings, the
book captured a performance of
yet another Italian
showman, Giovanni Piccini.
The book was later
reprinted, adapted,
and expanded countless times.
In fact, versions of that book
are still reprinted to this day.
Now, a few interesting things
about the performer
and the author.
OK. That's one of the
Cruikshank drawings.
Piccini was one of the best
known Punchmen of the period.
For nearly 50 years he had
been amusing lords, dukes,
princesses, squires, and
vagabonds throughout England.
And it was said that
everyone knew him
and they would stop
and watch his show.
As for John Payne Collier,
some of his works were labeled
forgeries and toward the end
of his life he more or less
admitted that everything
about his life had been a lie.
And there's no doubt that parts
of the Piccini script
were embellished.
It was a very verbose script
and could never be said
with Mr. Punch speaking all
those words through a swazzle.
However, whatever the arguments
are about Collier's honesty,
it is still felt that that
publication is what the French
call [foreign word],
a turning point,
because it provided a foundation
for everything else
that followed.
All right.
Here is a typical Punch and
Judy show from Piccini's time.
This is Punch or Mayday, 1829,
and this painting belongs
to the Tate Gallery in London.
Several interesting
things happened
between the mid to--
mid to late 1800's.
The railways came about
and eventually they
started making excursions
to the seaside.
With a greater number of people
now able to travel to the beach,
masses of people started
traveling there and soon Punch
and Judy followed them, along
with a printologist [phonetic],
oyster vendors, quack
doctors, and donkey rides.
So, while you were taking-- so
while you were taking a paddle
in the ocean, you could
now watch a live Punch
and Judy show.
In the very early days,
Punch and Judy shows were
originally attended--
intended for adult audiences
because they were the ones
that were paying
to watch the show.
Things started to change though
during the Victorian times.
The Victorians began to
invite Punch and Judy men
into their parlors to entertain
middle class drawing rooms
and at children's parties.
This is circa 1850.
Because of this, the street
showmen started to clean
up their act, so to speak, and
so Punch and Judy's image began
to soften and slowly evolve into
acceptable family entertainment.
During these Victorian times,
puppet characters were still
being added and deleted.
About 1860, the crocodile, one
of the more exciting characters
in the show, first
appeared and he's been
in the show ever since.
I thought you'd like this.
This is a great one.
You'll notice there's a dog
sitting up on the playboard.
And a dog is--
he was occasionally seen
in some performances.
In today's show, it's
usually he's just a puppet,
but back then he did
appear in some shows
and usually it was a
small terrier and it was--
belonged to the showman, it was
his pet, and he would travel
with him from town to town.
The dog was always called Toby
and he wore a colorful ruff
around its neck and sat on the
playboard during the sequences.
Mr. Punch would get the dog to
stand up on its two hind legs
and at times the dog would
get into a fight with Punch
and bite his noose--
I mean bite his nose.
It is interesting, a couple--
before, when I was coming in,
somebody was talking to me about
the dog-- and this is true--
that some of the dogs
would actually smoke a pipe
or a cigarette.
And-- anyway.
But today you rarely
see a live dog,
although you will see
a dog puppet in shows.
Now, there's a reason
why I included this.
This is what's known as a
saucy seaside British postcard.
I needed to get your attention
so that you would remember
three important things
about Punch and Judy.
And here they are.
Joey the clown, a slapstick,
and audience participation.
These three elements came
about through a unique form
of British entertainment
called pantomimes
or pantos [phonetic] for short.
Pantomimes are unique to England
and they have nothing
to do with mimes.
They are outlandish
musicals based
on well-known children's
stories, such as Peter Pan,
Jack and the Beanstalk,
Sleeping Beauty, et cetera.
This type of entertainment has
been taking place in England
for several hundred years
and always take place
around Christmastime.
There was a famous English
actor comedian known
as Joseph Grimaldi.
He played the part of a
clown and he was so popular
in these pantomimes that Punch
and Judy men added
him into their shows.
In fact, clowns today are
still known as Joeys and that's
in honor of Joseph Grimaldi.
Grimaldi and other characters
in the pantomime used
to hit each other with a wooden
slapstick, which is two pieces
of wood that when they hit
together they make a slapping
noise without causing
any real pain.
In fact, this is where the word
slapstick comedy comes from.
So, Punch and Judy performers
added slapstick comedy--
I mean the slapstick
to their shows.
And finally, the most
important part take
from British pantomimes is
the audience participation.
If you were in England
today attending a--
or around Christmastime--
attending a British pantomime
and a character said
oh, no, I didn't,
the entire audience would
automatically respond
and say oh, yes, you did.
Yeah. Well, thank you,
somebody has been there.
It's just a theatrical
tradition that's been handed
down from generation
to generation.
When the bad guy comes
out, everybody just boos.
I mean it's-- it's a sight
to see, it really is.
Over in England, Punch and Judy
is probably more popular now
than it's ever been.
It's estimated that
there are about 300 Punch
and Judy performers in England.
I would say here in
America we're lucky
if we have about 50, you know.
Now, I've jumped around
a bit and there's a--
but I've given you a general
overview of Punch and Judy
in England, so now I'd like to
talk a little bit about America.
We know that Punch was
here, at least by 1742.
A Philadelphia newspaper
advertisement announced the
performance of Punch and Joan.
See, didn't evolve yet.
Since the notice said the
figures were two feet high,
I think it's safe to say
that they were marionettes.
Not that long ago, I discovered
a 1902 book called Maryland
as a Palatinate and it
notes that there was a Punch
and Judy show in Annapolis,
Maryland before the
American Revolutionary War.
Per his own accounting records,
George Washington purchased a
ticket to a Punch and Judy show.
It wasn't long before
these Punch
and Judy shows began
popping up like mushrooms
after a good rainstorm.
Right after John Payne Collier's
book was released in England
in 1828, unauthorized editions
began-- were sold here.
Let's see, what do we got here.
OK. Now, if you have an interest
in Punch and Judy in America,
I highly recommend this book.
It's written by Ryan Howard.
It's Punch and Judy in
19th Century America.
Mr. Howard is a professor
emeritus of art history
at Moreland State University.
Years back, I was in the
early stages of writing a book
about the history of
Punch and Judy in America
when Mr. Howard contact
me and I told him
that I was writing a
book on the same subject.
Since he already had
a 15-year head start,
I thought it was a
good idea to just work
with him on the project.
I think my wife was
happy about that too.
But, truth be told, Mr.
Howard had already completed a
tremendous amount of work
and research on Punch
and Judy in the United States.
At one time there--
and this is true--
all this is true [laughs].
Why would it not be true?
I have a bad habit
of saying that.
This is true.
I don't know why I do that.
At one time there were
hundreds-- and I mean hundreds--
of Punch and Judy shows
barnstorming across America.
Some performers emigrated
from England
and other European countries.
Most Punch and Judy performers
were not full-time entertainers.
Many were part-time
magicians, ventriloquists,
and they learned how to
perform Punch and Judy
from other Punch
and Judy performers.
And I'm sure some operators
did what they had to do
in order to make a living.
Because of the diverse
American population at the time,
many of the early Punch
shows included racial
and ethnic characters,
dialect, and humor.
So, where did all these
shows take place in America?
They were everywhere.
They were performed at
parks, fairs, theaters,
and some venues that
no longer exist.
As an example, in the
late 1800's, some Punch
and Judy shows were
seen in concert saloons,
which were low-class
drinking establishments
that provided cheap
entertainment
and female companionship
to attract customers.
There were also variety
theaters.
The majority of Punch and
Judy show performers, however,
found employment at circus
side shows, dime museums,
and the Chautauqua circuit.
Oh, get that here.
OK. Ha, ha, ha.
Here we go.
This is probably one of the most
famous Punch and Judy performers
to work circus side shows
and it was none other
than the legendary
Harry Houdini.
Of course, he was very young at
the time and this is when he was
with the Welsh Brothers
Circus circus-- circa 1895.
It was said that Houdini carved
his own Punch and Judy puppets.
Now-- but sometime during
the 1970's, I guess it was
about 1975, I had a phone
call and someone was talking
to me about these puppets.
They either had them,
they knew where they were,
or they were selling them,
but I wasn't performing
Punch and Judy back then.
And I wish I could
remember more,
but I don't know how much you
can remember from phone calls,
you know, 40, 50 years ago.
Dime museums were
popular institutions
in the U.S. by the late 1800's.
They were designed as
centers for entertainment
and moral education
for the working class.
P. T. Barnum opened a dime
museum in New York back in 1842.
Eventually, some of the
museums featured Punch
and Judy shows along with other
types of variety entertainment.
The picture here is Gus White.
He's from Orange
County, New York.
And while he performed at many
county fairs, he also performed
for years at museums, some
of which were dime museums.
He was on a circuit and
traveled to Boston, Cleveland,
Coney Island, and
many other places.
I mentioned before
that most Punch
and Judy performers also did
other things to make a living.
Gus White was an
exceptional artist
and made a decent
living as a sign painter.
You should also note that he
was also an expert wood carver
and he made all his own puppets.
Just look at some
of the expressions
on the faces of those puppets.
At one time he had 32
characters that he could inject
into his show at any given time.
Since he was an amazing artist,
one of his features was
having Punch come up on stage
with a notepad and a crayon and
he would sketch out an image
of the president or
someone from the audience.
About 23 of his puppets survived
and they were auctioned off
in 1992, a New York comic
collector bought them
for $45,000.
OK. Then came Chautauqua.
This was a big adult education
movement from the late 1800's
to the mid-late 1920's.
Chautauqua assemblies brought in
all types of speakers, teachers,
musicians, and entertainers.
Their main purpose was to
bring entertainment, education,
and culture into
communities across America.
This is a picture of
Professor Will Smith.
He was originally from England
and he came from a long line
of Punch and Judy performers.
In 1921, he was performing
at a Chautauqua event
in Talbot County, Maryland.
I'll admit he looks a bit
scary dressed as Mr. Punch.
You know? This next
performer came later,
but there's a reason why
I'm highlighting him.
His name is George Prentice--
his real name was Michael
Zilka [assumed spelling]
and he is considered
a legend in the annals
of Punch and Judy history.
Even until today, the
Punch and Judy professors
over in England still talk
about him as if he were a god.
He performed in Vaudeville
and between 1931
and 1932 he performed 231 Punch
and Judy shows on Broadway
and a play called Laugh Parade
that starred comedian Ed Wynn.
In 1934, he was invited to
entertain the Duke of Windsor
at this royal wedding party.
Can you imagine that?
He stayed in England and
performed it for two years.
Some of his performances were
at the prestigious
London Palladium.
After appearing in
another Broadway show,
he toured Europe for six years.
His list of accomplishments
just go on and on.
He entertained the servicemen at
USO camps during World War II.
He performed in Vegas, many
popular shows of the day.
The man was everywhere.
One of his most prestigious
bookings was performing Punch
and Judy at Radio
City Music Hall.
That's a 6,200-seat theater.
One reviewer said his puppets
were a little hard to see,
but his comedy was universal.
It got laughs practically
all the way.
So, you might ask how
did I become interested
in Punch and Judy.
And if you don't ask
that, I'll ask it.
OK. It actually-- it dates
back to-- it's kind of weird,
but it actually goes back
to 1897 in Baltimore.
This is a photo here, a 1940
photo, of James Edward Ross.
He was known as Professor
Rosella and he first performed
at Pat Harris' dime museum
in Baltimore in 1897.
He would later go on
to perform his show
at Young's Million Dollar
Pier in Atlantic City
and for years he was featured--
he was a featured attraction
at a now defunct Baltimore
amusement park called Riverview.
One of his greatest
testimonials came
from President Theodore
Roosevelt
after watching one
of his performances.
Per Mrs. Roosevelt,
the president enjoyed Rosella's
Punch and Judy show more
than any child in the audience.
So, again, how did I become
interested in Punch and Judy?
This is a picture of George Horn
when he was a young magician.
He was a ventriloquist.
He met Rosella.
In fact, he was a
frequent visitor
to Riverview Amusement Park
where he watched
Rosella perform the show.
And George Horn performed
the show
in Baltimore for
nearly 60 years.
One of his strangest bookings--
George Horn's bookings--
was behind a two-way mirror at
a slanky [phonetic] night club
in Baltimore called
Club Charles.
The audience never
saw George Horn
and he worked there every night
for six night-- for six years.
His Punch and Judy puppets would
interact with audience members,
play musical instruments,
and again all behind
a two-way mirror.
If a regular person came in--
I mean a regular came in
with a new lady friend,
one of the puppets
would say, hey, Joe,
that's not the same lady you
brought in here the other night.
And all the bar flies
would laugh, you know.
So, when I was about
10 years old,
I saw George Horn perform Punch
and Judy and I never forgot it.
Or his name.
And as a child, I remember
calling him up on the phone
and telling him that I
was going to visit him--
and I did, 20, 25 years later.
Although I was performing
as a magician,
I hired him to entertain at
my niece's birthday party
and the children's reaction
to that show as amazing.
It was unlike anything
I had ever heard before.
He was in his late 80's and
since his wife had died,
we just became good friends
and for years I visited
him once a month
and would always take
him out to dinner.
In a nice way, I told him I'd
like to take over the show
if he ever decided that
he wanted to retire
and then one day he called
me up and told me that.
I studied under him for
years and was a pallbearer
at his funeral and he
died at the age of 98.
For a while, I actually thought
he was going to outlive me.
As of this year, I've been
performing a modified version
of the Rosella Horn
show under the banner
of Professor Horn for 25 years.
And that's my story.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]